el 30 de enero de 1972 soldados del
regimiento de paracaidistas de la élite
británica abrieron fuego en una protesta
por los derechos civiles en londonderry
13 personas fueron asesinadas y 14
quedaron heridas en un evento conocido
como pudo avisan de todos los fusilados
eran católicos irlanda del norte ahora
conmemora los eventos de distintas
maneras entre ellas realizando una obra
que representa una escena famosa del día
al final de un día tan conmovedor por
eventos que marcaron nuestra historia
espero que los familiares de las
víctimas de bloody sunday puedan
permitir que éste sea un lugar al menos
por esta tarde para dejar ir ese dolor
dejar ir ese amor sufrimiento culpa
dejar ir todo en 2010 una investigación
judicial determinó que las víctimas del
bloody sunday eran inocentes y que no
suponían ninguna amenaza para los
militares pero pocos meses después
fiscales anunciaron que el único soldado
británico acusado de asesinato no
enfrentaría a juicio el año pasado el
gobierno británico vaticinó sus planes
de detener los juicios de los soldados y
militantes una medida que no a algunos
es muy difícil obtener la reconciliación
o cualquier cosa en esa dirección cuando
el gobierno británico está tratando de
cerrar la puerta a esa posibilidad con
su especie de inmunidad general para las
fuerzas armadas
por esfuerzos las heridas de los
familiares de las víctimas del bloody
sunday aún no han sanado